[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
i'm heather ruth and i'm anna wayne and
this is your news for Monday December
4th well first of all it would not be an
orbit report if we didn't address
there's Titans news that's right this
week we saw the first look at Robin
he had a character like poster almost
because I got a shot he's going yes
really see what he's going to look like
and his costume looks pretty good I'm
really excited about it only the upper
part right right you know we saw it's
all we saw yeah it looked almost like a
video game
yes there was like a certain Sheen to it
that I think is really interesting if
that's gonna be a stylized choice that
they make for this television series it
could work absolutely definitely work
yeah and again I think there was some
confusion last time this is for Titans
which is going to be a live-action TV
series that's gonna premiere in 2018 on
the DC streaming service whatever that's
gonna be released I still have no
release dates for any of this but now we
officially have our picture of Robin and
I'm hyped about it he even has the staff
yes it's Tim Drake Robin so it's gonna
be one of the first times we've seen
Robin in live-action for a while in
casting news this week we got some big
news about our Mulan oh that's right
we've got our Mulan it's going to be Liu
Yifei
and she looks pretty spot-on I'm very
excited she's a Chinese actress that's
very well-known in China in America
she's done so a couple Hollywood
features outcast and Forbidden Kingdom
yeah so she's got some action experience
she sings apparently yes she does though
I mean she's got some big shoes to fill
because Bing now and who is the original
one is incredible but I got to tell you
I think she can handle these I mean
especially with
her action background salutely I think
that's a great choice she's also popular
in China so she's gonna bring those box
office you know sales yeah yeah although
now I'm interested to see what they're
gonna do with the male lead of this
movie yeah are they going to go with the
Chinese actor that I need American actor
the better are we gonna go the memoirs
litigation route and just pick some
other Asian nationality into that don't
do that I mean there's so many Chinese
American or Chinese actors for them
break from but it'll be really
interesting to see who exactly is gonna
get cast now as our male lead leader Yue
Fei is also she's duolingo so he studied
in America as well so she does English
and Chinese so we've we've got that
covered so I it's possible guys there
are so many people out there we can do
this we can make it good although you
better put make a man out of your song
in there otherwise I'm walking out I'm
walking out after you've got my ticket
sales already that's it that'll be the
straw that breaks the camel's name I
think it's really interesting that they
cast someone older not yes but like not
a teenager who's like overly things yeah
so that that makes it like able to be a
little more serious reap it on that
child that it thinks is a young boy
that's just a different vibe I think
maybe Disney's shying away from yeah so
yeah also this week we saw a trailer for
all the money in the world now you're
saying to yourself Ayanna I saw this
trailer like two months ago I did you're
right so here's the thing though Kevin's
face is not in it anymore
so you didn't see this trailer the new
trailer came out this week and it's
Christopher Plummer is going to be
playing the lead role so they did all
those reshoots because that's coming out
on December 22nd Wow that's pretty fast
uh and that's he's the title role in it
so that's pretty much a lot to have to
reshoot however it's directed by Ridley
Scott so gonna be amazing
also it's based on a true story that I
find fascinating
you don't know the story you should look
into it or I'll tell you a little bit
about it right now
so Jay paul Getty is oil tycoon really
rich man like like super rich like one
of the richest man in history rich and
his grandson was kidnapped his grandson
was 16 year old at the time in 1973 in
Rome and obviously ransom demands came
in and Jay Paul kid he was like no I'm
not doing that my grandson is just
trying to like leave me of my money and
I'm not doing that
okay so then one ransom demand was
delayed by the post because of an
Italian post strike and then another
ransom came in and contained the
grandsons like a lock of his hair in his
ear so so I guess it's real now they're
like yeah you better give us this money
otherwise we're just gonna send it back
in pieces
what that's insane and then so the
grandfather is like okay I'm taking this
seriously but still refusing to pay
because like I've got you know 14 other
grandchildren what if they just kidnap
someone else I'm just telling the
kidnappers yeah I can have my
grandchildren I'll just give you my
money so he's like nope not paying it
and then finally was able to talk the
road summers down negotiated handled the
price I'm that his grandsons ransom
great good job buddy um and so he ended
up paying a 2.2 million which is that
like highest amount that you can count
as tax deductible bro seriously and then
the remaining amount he loaned it to his
son who is Jay paul Getty jr. because
this the grandson is Jay paul Getty is
the third so like his namesake
he wouldn't even pay for um so he loaned
the remaining amount of the ransom to
his son with interest dude you got so
much money are you freaking kidding me
right now he's not oh my goodness I'm so
excited to see this I'm also I'm just a
big fan of true crime in general
yeah like any true crime like things
that come out I'm in you listen to
podcast my favorite murder it's great um
so there's my favorite kidnapping it's I
find this case fascinating
sounds and it's just right with drama
like there's so much to explore I'm sure
it's gonna be dramatized right so like
come on users are not material already
there that seems like they're not gonna
have to do that's right there's so much
material in fact that with this movie
coming out in December in January of
2018 FX has a new anthology series
that's coming out called trust the first
season of which is going to be this
kidnapping all right well there we go
we've got plenty to discover from this
case yeah I'm very excited another
trailer that we had dropped this week
that like maybe maybe you guys heard
about I don't know it's Avengers
infinity war I mean obviously we are
super excited about this and it broke
records within the first 24 hours it has
become the most watched trailer on
YouTube so it's already broken records
you guys aren't rewatching in a million
times we're we watching it a million
times there was just so much that was
stuffed into this trailer and it felt
real it was a really well done trailer
and I feel like it gave us just enough
to be hints but not enough to be totally
spoilery enough for me to want to watch
it like 10 or how could seem long little
stuff we got a couple of characters with
all new look that's right Black Widow is
blonde girl traitor
crazy and captain has beers yeah
America's got a beer also we're keeping
the eye patch on Thor I mean it makes I
know working for right but one of the
things that surprised me the most was it
appeared that Tony Stark had an arc
reactor yeah are we just like pretending
half of Iron Man 3 didn't happen or is
there something that's going to happen
to Tony that's gonna make him reinstall
reactor I was just blown away by saying
that and in that scene it appeared like
everyone else was frozen in time except
him so I don't know what's happening
with with Iron Man but his arc reactor
that yeah I don't know and also there's
gonna be a Hulkbuster suit
that's right it was so cool yes we saw
that hand sitting there almost like for
reference yes this is the Hulkbuster
hand this is Mark Ruffalo and that scene
too even appeared like that was the
first time that Black Widow and Hulk
were seeing each other like the first
time well ready field I know
and then vision at one point almost had
a human skin
so I don't know if it's another Android
suit or if it's some kind of hologram
that he's projecting himself to like
blend in and it weirded me out at first
all right there's a human with the mine
stone I get that means it's vision but
it was a little weird yeah it was and
then we saw him with his mind stone
being pulled out I don't know which I
mean who know has to happen obviously
it's not it happened but then what does
that mean right is he gonna die I don't
think so I think there's gotta be some
kind of backup system in place they
obviously know that this is gonna be a
possibility then someone's gonna come
after his infinity stone there's got to
be something in place for a backup
system or maybe his consciousness is
just gonna be spread throughout the
internet and we're gonna have to try to
reconstruct it right there's got to be
some kind of back-up plan for that yeah
and one of the other things that I found
interesting was it didn't appear that
Thanos had his armor on this time now
he's just got the Infinity Gauntlet his
armor is gone some people have said
maybe it's a to show transition between
being a warlord to being the big bad the
villain himself and we already saw that
his gauntlet had one of the Infinity
stones the one from the Nova Corps which
I mean makes sense than of course not
amazingly competent David punched some
people and got himself an infinity stone
but then we also saw him put on the
tesseract stone so I don't know what
that means for locus yeah Loki you come
on what happened to your character arc
there buddy
we just going back to your old ways
apparently I don't know I don't know I
know especially we saw him like stepping
over body yeah bro I'm upset with you
possibly one of the best moments in the
trailer is but I just keep referring to
as what kind of squad go yeah
Steve leading the pack of some of the
Avengers against the aliens charge and
oh they look amazing not even worried I
just don't write any like sweet there
was a smaller moment earlier in the
trailer to where we get to see the
spidey sense of like appears yeah I was
pretty cool the circle and it seems to
be a lot of circle yeah I mean I think
that Thor's circle is maybe him forging
his new hammer in a dying star no
there's just so much to break down with
material er let us know in the comments
below guys what you guys what your
trailer what what you think's happening
with the infinity war my only concern is
that it's a little jam-packed yeah
there's one laughs you know or the one
there's a lot that's gonna happen
so they earned it though they we do
there's so many movies and like they've
earned this final like hey here's
guardians of the galaxy like a lot of
like build up to this so you're gonna
have to see the other ones you know at
this point you're gonna have to but
they've earned it
but is it too much I don't know you're
worried we're just gonna have that's not
that's my one worry yeah gonna be a lot
it is well I think that's gonna be it
from us here guys um Heather where can
people find you in social media you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash other routes and as usual you can
find me on Facebook as I own aways or
everywhere else as awesome Ayana in the
meantime let us know in the comments
down below your thoughts on infinity war
or anything else we didn't get to cover
this week or that we should look forward
to next week
otherwise that's gonna be it from us
here so we'll catch you next week in the
meantime hey can you beam us up
[Applause]
you